rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message maintain positivity over
to you will Smith
he was always challenge for that right
like all yourself you're different the
positivity was always challenged yeah I
always want you to justify being
positive right absolutely yeah now that
was a that was a difficult time coming
up cuz it's like I'm from I'm from
Philly right so during that time in
Philly it was Joe Frazier and rocky so
this fight was common yeah Chuck D used
to he called it pug City
he's like pug City is like he's like
chuckles like you can't go to Philly
without getting in a fight so it's like
I grew up in that so for me too
it was always difficult for people you
know to say I was soft and I was you
know my music was cotton candy you know
that's all I always wanted to fight to
try to to prove myself but the be
fighting yourself to maintain positivity
as the hardest fight you ever gonna have
right and it's like that struggle to
just stay my course to you know be the
person in the world that that I wanted
to be no matter what people said and it
was a I started to call it offensive
positivity right like you know I wasn't
gonna be on defense with my positivity I
was gonna be on offense with it what do
you stand for as a human being what do
you stand for you have to find the thing
that you stayin for that you believe in
so much that when people laugh at you
when people tell you your
people tell you impossible it is
impossible to move you from that
position that when you're faced with
negativity and opposition and people
telling you you're crazy you will not
budge you will not move from where you
were going because you are so solid in
what you stand for it's the only way you
win
so Will Smith is about positivity and
when he was starting off that hurt him
it was hard coming out of Philly when
everything was about violence and being
the man and fighting and being the
positive guy that was hard and made his
path harder but ultimately helped define
him in his career and why you love going
to Will Smith for me it's about belief
that's my one word every piece of
content that I put out is around believe
somehow is trying to spread that same
vibe of positivity and so it would be a
lot easier for me to stand out and win
in the short term if I made negative
content I think negative content out
pulls positive if I made a video on the
top 10 stupidest things Donald Trump has
said are the top 10 reasons you should
hate Kanye West those videos would take
off those would be fire people love
spreading negativity you love seeing how
stupid or how dumb or how bad somebody
else is because it makes you feel better
about your life and I hate that I hate
running away from a negative life I want
people to build a better life for
themselves and so even though in the
short run that hurts me those videos the
ones that I put up that are positive
that our unbelief will do worse than the
negative ones I still do it because it's
what I stand for it's because believe is
that the courts my one word it's Who I
am it's the pillar that I am on that you
cannot shake me from no matter how much
you yell at me or laugh for me and tell
me this is not gonna work I have no
choice I have to do this thing because
it's Who I am and it's ultimately how I
am gonna win and so the message isn't
that you have to believe in positivity
or you have to believe and believe
positive that's what Will Smith is all
about believe is what I'm all about what
are you all about as a human being what
is your one word what are you staying
for what are you gonna be on that pillar
that nobody will move you from even if
they are laughing at you insulting you
telling you that
we'll never work because when you figure
that out when you know from a foundation
level what you stand for as a human
being everything in life becomes easier
everything in your business becomes
easier it may take you a long time still
to get to the ambition level that you
have it may take you a long time still
to get to that level of impact that you
want to have the level of money that you
want to have the love of success that
you want to have but you are certain you
are certain that this is the path and
every time you betray who you are you
lose now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what are you staying for what
will you not be moved from let me know
put it down the comments below
people got choices I hate that people
act like they don't have a choice you
know you got a choice in any and
everything you do here's one thing that
I'll say to your listeners and when I
say it just think about it do you know
how much energy and time it takes to be
angry do you know how much time it takes
to hold a grudge to really muster up the
energy to hold on to a grudge I don't
like you every time I see you I gotta
let you know I don't like you I don't
like you I'm that's energy right and I'm
throwing I'm throwing all this stuff I'm
throwing all this stuff your way and
that's energy that I could use to going
to something else like I would not think
about my time I think about my energy I
think about my efforts how much time and
energy do I really have and how much do
I want to put into stuff that's not
going to affect me on a day-to-day basis
just negative just nonsense nonsense I
mean what I don't have the time for it
that's why the negativity that the
negativity that I have received I
respond what crime is you find what
you're looking for I've been giving a
lot of thought to kind of just watching
what I'm seeing out there in the social
digital ecosystem and very honestly just
real life and I'm watching so many
people over the last two to three years
look for negativity look for something
that's wrong find where people disagree
with them fight look for what was me
downside the half glass empty and then I
go to a Twitter search or look around
the world and I find ridiculously
beautiful things every day every day
thousands of kind acts randomly by
people all people that I have
conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypto or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong while there's plenty of wrong and
plenty of right in the world it comes
down to one very simple thing what are
you choosing to look for because I
promise you if you right now and I'm
making this video for one reason 24
hours of trying to find the good
somebody saves a kid somebody opens the
door somebody does a nice thing for you
bit somebody says thank you 24 hours of
looking for positivity could change your
life honestly making us for one person's
one one person watches this video
chooses to do 24 hours of looking for
good instead of looking for bad and
their game changes d-roc heard somebody
at a convenience store saying mom you're
always so negative
you're always so negative I am blown
away by the fact that life gets real
simple if you break down into this are
you looking for the negative this sucks
this government sucks this person sucks
this is are you looking for the positive
she's nice that's remarkable I've got
this opportunity you choose what you're
looking for because what you look for
you find that's how can life works
you know I speak for the underdogs and I
speak for the young the young generation
of young dudes and young women right now
who I feel like you know we live in a
constant lifestyle I talk about the
lifestyle so I don't make music about
you know just a bunch of chains and cars
and because clearly you've seen what a
bunch of changes and stuff like that is
not my life but I do make music about
the real things that we see on a daily
basis it you know I make music about the
problems that we go doing you know I
speak for these young kids over there so
my message really is try to bring light
today situation try to print a godly
like today situation and everything that
I do because you know that's that's
that's the side that I'm fighting for
footing for the hopes I decided hope the
side that says no there's a little bit
more than what you think is out there
that could help you know his music is
gonna be therapeutic so that's gonna get
you to certain times that maybe you may
not felt like it was gonna get figured
out it you know so that's the message
that I'm trying to push is just I'm
gonna bring that light to the generation
because that's what I'm here to to raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
values is that people with passion
and not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's suppose to mean now
if you want to learn more from will
check out the top ten rules vol 5 that I
did on him it's right next to me I think
I'm gonna enjoy it continue to believe I
hope you enjoyed today's shot a
vinspresso
and I'll see you on the next video
working on on your body is the beginning
of everything